Veronica Wang pokey maid Elena tea and
raywilliamjohnson what do all these
people have in common their coffee
striker that's right
all these people have history of copy
striking videos now there's nothing
inherently wrong about coffee striking
okay but I think the motivation behind
these copyright strikes is worth
mentioning at least recently James key
made a video talking about how his
channel face getting she almost shut
down because he got a copyright strike
over someone not liking what he said in
a video now I personally have a lot of
experience with copyright and I think
it's for the best interest of everyone
on this site that we talked about this
in today's video and also so I can get
more watch time so do keep watching guys
ray william johnson remember a rebellion
johnson copyright strike a channel
called hoover ray william johnson
himself I'm pretty sure took down the
video now I have no idea why he did but
I checked the claim he claimed the
entire video to 12 minutes the entire
thing so the outro was is the original
bits I put in where his departs where we
just talked where his no normally out of
final appeal obviously but the thing is
if he's taking on the whole video and
then he this looks at the appeal and he
[ __ ] takes it down
that's the copyright strike on my ass
there's no real good parts of this so
the title of the video that was taken
down by ray william johnson was
interestingly ray william johnson thinks
he can sing and it was basically a video
mocking raveling johnson's old singing
career or his old music essentially and
he begs the question would this video
have been taken down if it was called
raveling johnson sings like an angel ray
william johnson underrated musical
genius I don't think so
ok now the video is back up again so I
assume they resolved this but I think
it's important to note that this didn't
just get resolved because ray william
johnson thought to himself maybe I
shouldn't have taken down that video
I'll remove the claim no it got most
likely thanks to a lot of youtubers
raising their voice and helping this
channel
and a lot of public outrage on Twitter
the copyright claim got removed I find
this extremely hypocritical coming from
someone that even went to court to fight
for fair use raywilliamjohnson who made
a career essentially from other people's
content reacting to it adding their own
commentary to it just like Hoover did
now to be fair I appreciate that
raywilliamjohnson took down the claim I
also can't say for sure what the
motivation behind the claim was
originally I can't say for a fact that
it was because people were ridiculing
him I think what we'll find today here
is a common theme people just didn't
like what was in the video
therefore it was taken down I already
know example of illinit II but I'll
bring it up because I think is important
nonetheless this is so annoying
stupid twitch thought uni they win over
me okay and they're not gonna win over
me stupid twitch thoughts no seriously
he use that that I'm gonna copy strike
this guy just for that word gonna copy
strike him yo so I didn't even call
Alena D a twitch thought I just used a
word basically that was enough for her
to think oh I'm gonna claim the revenue
out of that video and it I think this
revealed the second problem with
copyright strikes they sending me 700
dollars last month from copy strike
hitting people good money so this reveal
the second problem with copyright strike
which is the motivation for monetary
games of striking other people's content
basically if you claim a video you get
all that revenue from that video so
illinit e here try to use the motivation
of he used two bad word against me so
therefore i all that revenue in that
video that's mine now thank you very
much my revenue oh I was in that
person's video yes I mean it's basically
theft and there's so many companies that
partner up with streamers specifically
just so they can claim reuploaded
content on YouTube which in a way I can
understand but I also find it extremely
ironic because usually streamers
commentary is just them sitting there
they're not adding any
thing to it I don't even know why people
bother reuploading these at least
youtubers can argue that their work is
transformative understand each other the
world will be a better place that's
right that's all I care about
I just want people to be happy trust me
that's my number one priority smash like
on this video sorry we'll get that abuse
that would help me out a lot thank you
very much for watching make sure to hit
sponsor it so become a sponsor so you
can see that and that's it for me for
now thank you guys so much for watching
I'll see you guys - okay
hey Shrout hit subscribe goddammit what
are you doing I'm not here to call shout
out okay on anything else but him
subscribing third example Exhibit C
Veronica Wang disappointing I thought I
gave her the benefit of the doubt but
basically she striked a channel to the
point that it almost got deleted why why
because she didn't like what that
channels content was about her she
didn't like how the video was making fun
of her and she didn't like how people
watching the video making fun of her was
making even more fun of her essentially
I'm a representation to my subscribers
and I want to show them that it's okay
to stand up for yourself
so I made a video of me making fun of
myself literally a video of me making
fun of myself to show people you know if
anyone's gonna be allowed to make fun of
me it's gonna be me so this reveals
another big problem in my opinion which
is fairly similar to the pokey -
situation Exhibit D pokey main she
strike this video called keemstar versus
Pokemon Twitter fight bullying Sniper
Wolf fanboy now I know about this video
because it was pushed everywhere by
YouTube it was basically a Twitter feud
between keemstar and pokey mind they
uploaded videos to each other I don't
know cuz King sir is illiterate and for
some reason Pokemon decided yeah I'll
make a video as well none that
nevertheless someone decided to put
these two videos in together and upload
it on YouTube then the YouTube algorithm
thought oh this is an interesting video
that people want to watch and pushed it
everywhere so basically this Twitter
drama became even bigger drama thanks
YouTube's algorithm so in a way I can
understand why you want to take down
this video because this selected thing
blows up and becomes even bigger thanks
to YouTube system being kind of stupid
at least I can somewhat understand the
motivation of trying to take down that
video but the problem here and the same
problem that goes with every single
example that I brought up in this video
is that you're just drawing more
attention to it
it's the Streisand effect every single
time the more you try and hide something
the more people are gonna find out about
it that's what brought all these
examples to lie and I think what bothers
me most of all out of all of these is
the hypocrisy you know ray william
johnson went to court for fair use but
strikes another channels content for
uploading his okay all these people that
i brought up today have examples of
using other people's content for their
own content they could all get copyright
striped just the same way they copyright
strike other people or claim their
videos i don't know exactly what the
percentage is but i would say 90% of
content on the internet or at least on
YouTube in twitch isn't hundred percent
original content it's its commentary its
reactions its reviews its gameplay
I mean people tell me all the time oh
just make original content well guess
what every single gaming channel is not
original content they're reacting to
someone else's video game it's someone
else's content they don't own the rights
to it just the same way with any other
reaction but it's fair use because it's
transformative work because you're
adding your commentary to it remember
when Sean vanaman decided to give me a
DMCA takedown a copyright strike because
he didn't like what I said in a live
stream that had nothing to do with his
game despite the fact that they give
public permission on their website
you're free to use our game so basically
they can revoke that at any given time
if anyone if you have permission to use
someone's content they can still give
you a copyright strike because basically
YouTube doesn't pay attention to any of
that I feel pretty confident that if I
took Sean venneman to court or his
company to fight this claim which is
basically what a DM Said's
that would in entitles if I fight
against it but I feel confident that I
would win that and wasting him and his
company time and money well my time as
well obviously it's not cheap either I
mean h3h3 went to court any constant one
hundreds of thousands of dollars fifty
thousand dollars I think they hailed up
a check for but the problem here is a
YouTube's way so insanely heavily
towards the one making the claim the way
the system works and I'll explain this
for the hundredth time I'm sorry for all
this doing it you can either get a claim
or a copyright strike if the video gets
claimed the video saves up but they take
all the revenue if you get a copyright
strike the video goes down but they
still take all the revenue if a video
gets claimed you as a creator have the
choice to dispute that claim in saying
no you're wrong for doing this claim and
it's basically solely up to the one
making the claim to say actually no I'm
right so you're not just getting money
but you also dictate whether you're
right or wrong the system is so messed
up and if you say no twice to the clay
to the claim it automatically goes to a
copyright strike so basically as a
creator if you get a claim you're you're
pretty screwed but if you're the one
making the claim there's basically no
repre conscience I mean you could claim
whatever you want YouTube isn't gonna go
hey stop doing that and as a creator you
just risk your channel getting shut down
I mean that's what happened to James key
now because of him getting a copyright
strike if you get a copyright claim and
you say okay we'll take this to court
then that's the only way we can settle
this the history of this happening which
is two examples h3 h3 and
raywilliamjohnson and they both argue
that their content was transformative
and fair and it applies under fair use
and guess what they want making
commentary on own videos and adding your
reactions and all that - it does apply
under fair use at least from what we've
seen so far so if you copyright strike a
channel or even claim a channel you run
the risk of actually going to court and
losing a lot of money so it's generally
a terrible idea to abuse this system
which so many people seem to do without
even thinking about the wreck
questions because YouTube doesn't really
apply it instantly it is a terrible idea
to do this not just for monetary
purposes but also because everyone will
hate you I mean the only thing really
holding the YouTube system together at
this point it's the public outcry or the
public outrage towards people that abuse
the system and if that wasn't the case I
mean the whole thing would just go
rampant you also just draw more
attention to what you're trying to hide
so just stop can you just stop abuse and
copyright it's not that hard just don't
take down videos even if it shows you in
a negative way it's a terrible idea
stop doing it stop taking down videos
YouTube needs to add a takedown request
the only way to take down a video right
now is through a copyright strike a
takedown request let's just say okay you
give the user two to three days to take
down the video and then if they say no
at that period then it goes to a
copyright strike the way it works right
now is the only way to take down a video
is through a copyright strike I think
having a takedown request would solve a
lot of problems I mean there's been
times where me myself had to do a
copyright strike because there was a
video I just wanted to be shown for a
specific time and I asked people please
don't really this video because they
only wait for me to take it down is to
give it a copyright strike and people
did it anyway people still real go to
the video and I was like alright well I
have to give you a copyright strike now
like I didn't want to do this but
YouTube has no other way to take down a
video so a takedown request at least
would be some fair warning in between at
least now my final point I'm sorry it's
been super long my final point is a few
years back Nintendo announced that
basically to upload Nintendo games on
YouTube you need to be part of their
partnership program me personally and a
lot of other people criticized this idea
because it's just a bad idea you're just
gonna miss out on a lot of free
marketing which is basically what this
is people playing games and lo and
behold now they announced they're
shutting the program down the way the
ecosystem YouTube works
or on the Internet in general is that
most people benefit from sharing these
different things
game developers know that it's free
marketing for people to play their games
they even pay youtubers to play their
game they even pay to make it seem like
it there are youtubers playing their
game even though they're just actors
that's how effective this whole sharing
thing works the ecosystem works people
watching and reacting to other people's
videos that helps that creator they
receive some of sharing content is
something that everyone benefits from
not just for promotion but also it makes
everything so much more fun in my
opinion it's what makes memes fun and
all these different references and
whatever it's already so bad with people
abusing copyright strikes just stop
copyright striking videos okay just stop
making it worse for literally everyone
YouTube's tool have the tools for
everyone to make a copyright strike stop
abusing it it's bad enough already
now with article 13 you've probably
already heard about it's just gonna make
it even worse there's 11 days left
before an article 13 will be decided
upon I highly encourage you to sign this
petition right now sign the petition we
need to protect the internet YouTube
system works it works too good that's
the problem
stuff we'll be using the system and sign
this goddamn tradition that's it thank
you guys so much love you guys so much
see you guys tomorrow bye bye you
thought the video was over 80 million
club merch is here everybody can we
copies right this guy
80 million club that's right everybody
thank you for 80 million subscribers cuz
yeah very epic Merc check it out link in
the description limited time only
sayonara bro sugamice what the actual